what's up everyone welcome back to the
cinema center at Marvel at Tiff 2023 I
am lucky enough to be sitting here with
John Carney talking about one of my
favorite films of the whole damn year
fell in love with flora and Sun at
Sundance and I was so happy you were
bringing it here so we had a chance to
talk oh me too I'm delighted to chat so
I want to go back to the beginning with
this and even back a little further
because I know you veered away from
feature filmmaking for a little bit what
inspired that shift and when you got
back to it were there any new tools that
you were able to use on flora and son
that you knew you gained from Siri
storytelling that's a cool question
probably yes I I the reason I stopped
making movies for a while was that I
needed to buy a house so I went and made
television which got me enough money to
buy a house and then I returned to
filmmaking to get some furniture in the
house this makes all sensible sense of
how big TV is and how but so Flora was a
return as tiny small film that kind of
returned to my comfort zone of you know
not a lot of money and cast I knew and
friends of mine and crew that I had come
up with
um and I think I probably did learn a
lot by making you know Modern Love which
is the TV show that you're referring to
um you do learn to tell a story in a
very succinct way when you're working
within TV that they were Standalone
episodes so I think I learned a lot
about
um getting scripts down to their bare
kind of minimum and finding a way to
tell a story very quickly and
effectively and uh and kind of getting
on with it and I think that probably
shows in Flora's fairly so it's a short
enough movie you know it's not a huge
long sprawling movie I'm ruining my road
map here but because you just referenced
the fact that you brought back a whole
bunch of collaborators you've worked
with in the past to make flora and Sun
just because like everyone everyone
knows you we're going to talk about Eve
Joseph all those people can you give me
an example of maybe someone behind the
scenes that you have an established
relationship with that I don't know
might be a bit of an unsung hero and you
want our audience to know about what
they bring to your projects wow there
are a lot of people that I work
one of The Producers on on
um Flora produce begin again and sing
the streets and we we now have clocked
up quite a few films together and we'll
continue to do so and then there were
various crew members in Ireland
that I had worked with I've been working
with for kind of years we both started
you know we many of us started making
films just as a sort of a thing to do
you know picked up a camera one guy
picked up a microphone the other picked
up a Clapper board and you found out
what job you were doing you know we
didn't go to college really it was it
was more like I need you to do the
makeup or will you do this or get
sandwiches and jobs became kind of came
out of necessity which is really
interesting sort of way of working well
when you find those collaborators and
you know they're the real deal the
long-term ones you stick with them I
love it talking about how a film can
evolve throughout the entire filmmaking
process so do you remember what the
biggest differences between Florence and
draft one and what everyone will now see
in the finished feature yeah I can I I
wrote that script and I paused on about
page 50 or 60 and I didn't know which
way I kind of let it sit there for quite
a few months actually without an ending
um and I had every all the characters
were set up and then I once I knew was
going to be Eve I I figured out the way
to sort of end this
um and where to go and to play to her
strength she's a very funny person and
that was immediately evident the second
I kind of met her was like well she's
gonna go in
always with the funny bone and and and
she's not afraid of
goofing around and dripping up and
trying different things and saying well
that didn't work and that and I think
that sort of led me
to to complete the script and finish it
out knowing the the voice of the of the
actor who was going to play Flora I'd
also read when you stopped after page 50
you also focused on the music and I
think the way you described it was
initially like the music just it wasn't
right so what did that music sound like
and when you found her and figured out
the end of the script how did the music
evolve from there so the music in this
movie usually with the musical The the
criteria is give me the best song you
have that's all it is you know if A Star
is Born or Guys and Dolls like what's
the best Vibes or Falling Slowly in the
film I did called once it's the best
song you can write please
with this it's slightly different
because they have to be good songs but
they have to plausibly be from the Flora
character who let's face it found a
guitar at the beginning of this movie
and never played before so she can't
suddenly be uh Django Reinhardt who was
mentioned in the movie you know she
can't suddenly be up and down the
fretboard okay so now her her songs are
probably going to be down here in G and
c and F's and she's probably not going
to be dropping insus and Major Seventh
chords and Jazzy stuff so that's an
interesting and I didn't look at them as
limitations but it was the character
that I had written was was forming the
song so that should tell you which
direction to take the songs in and it
took a while to figure out what sand she
she's producing so so so good so much
that I can't get out of my head and I'm
happy for it I wanted to live there
forever and ever
um talking a little bit about Eve now
and also actually all the leads you've
worked with over the years you've had
some pretty exceptional leads in a movie
musical do you notice any shared
qualities they have that make them Excel
with a film like this but then also can
you name something about her that makes
her one of a kind and stand out from the
bunch yeah I think I'm probably looking
for
um actors for whom music
it's the question that I ask of all of
the actors when we're kind of getting
down she's like what how much of a role
does music play in your life because
believe it or not people for some people
music is kind of background which always
amazes me
um and so I'm always kind of looking for
the story in an actor's life for a music
really changed them or a song or or a
period of their life in which they grew
or
messed up or uh got married or didn't
get married what was the music playing
what was the score of your life and I I
think I've always gravitated towards
actors for whom music played of kind of
a pivotal role in their in their life
and then then that's it I don't go into
that in too much detail on the set or
anything like that but it's good to know
that the person because my films I guess
are kind of about music uh changing your
life and uh so so it's good to have
actors who have their own personal
experience of that and then how about
something about her that stands out from
any lead you've ever worked with before
uh so many things she just she she Eve
is very unusual she doesn't come at it
like an actor uh that I or the actors
that I've known she's she's perfectly
studious she learns her lines and she's
an actor but she comes at it from a
slightly different perspective which I
really enjoyed
um
and I'm not sure what it is that she's
got uh but I I haven't seen it you know
in Mark Ruffalo or
like I'm trying to think of other actors
that I've that I've worked with who have
a very kind of um
you know went to acting school or or she
has I guess what I'm trying to say is
more a little bit more of the lead
singer of a band a little bit more of a
rock star uh let's face it just her
approach to things is a little bit like
it reminds me when she's talking it
reminds me of fans I've been in or lead
singers that I've met just they they
think in three minute increments or
something like the length of a song I
definitely I'm not you know I know I'm
not going to be able to do that or that
doesn't ring true or just a funny
musical sort of approach to the thing
and then her humor was the other thing
that Drew me to because the character is
funny and she she was not that in any
moment she never said can I look back at
that because I think I've made a fool of
myself she was like you can have that
take if you want us yeah I was reading a
lot about how she is game to do just
about anything can you give us an
example of a surprising big swing she
took on set you loved it rolled with it
now everyone can see in the Finish Line
she's just doing bad sisters and I think
hanging with Sharon and all of those
great actors she was
that it probably I don't know but it
seems when you're watching that show
they were just having a brilliant time
making that show
so she was very up for like I'll try I
don't know if I'm this or that or if I
can do this funny but there were
definitely a couple of episodes we would
arrive on set and myself and Eve would
be a little bit like I'm a bit bored
today I was let's do it funny just for
our own entertainment what about
tripping up I'm like trying to go
underneath the wall like there were
certain scenes where
you know with the ex-boyfriend with Jack
Rayner her ex-husband where she had to
try and have Poise but but didn't
because she's the Wounded Woman coming
back to drop the kid off or something
and she was very funny and very open to
letting him have the scene and her kind
of play the fool and not not have to try
and get a back off him and there were
numerous episodes I think where where
myself and Eve would look at each other
and kind of have a little code which is
like do something funny this scene needs
it needs some we need to take the air
you know it's she was really good at
that I get the impression that she could
do absolutely anything and after this I
just need her to be the lead of more and
more feature films in the future I have
to talk about Joe briefly because I had
heard that I think he said this actually
that initially you were thinking maybe
you wanted to cast a professional uh
musician in that role did you have any
particular musician in mind and then
what did he write in that letter to you
that convinced you otherwise so so um
you know like it doesn't take much
convincing to get Joe you know in your
movie we would all love to work with
Joseph Gordon-Levitt but it's the I had
this idea that he was somehow very good
looking and
sophisticated and polite it was just a
thing I had if I thought of him I was
like oh he's the good guy in you know he
wears ties and he looks good and I'm
talking about a you know Sun Sun tanned
La hippie who's been fat you know who's
failed in his career and lives up in
Topanga Canyon or wherever and I just
was like isn't he a bit clean cut and
aren't you and he was like no I I know
La I know this guy and he he just spoke
so well about music and he spoke about
his own wife and the way that they sing
together and he talked about harmonizing
with your partner which really spoke to
me and
I felt like here is a guy who who knows
this character in a way that I didn't
even really know when I kind of wrote
him uh and he he was like you don't it's
very very nice when a director when an
actor comes to a director and says you
don't see that you have something here
let me point this out to you and you can
as a director it's very humbling and
inviting to go oh I didn't see that and
you're grateful because an actor has
shown you something that you didn't know
you had in in a script or an idea and
Joe did that in numerous times because
he is let's face it has 50 times more
experience than I do so lots of times
I'd be like he's he's Joe he's you know
uh yes well I want to go down that path
a little more now maybe I'll maybe I'll
phrase it this way going into filming
which character were you most excited to
work on and dig into but then to lean
into what you were just saying which
character wound up being more more
creatively fulfilling than you ever
could have imagined because of what the
actor brought out of what you had
written well I tell you jack Rayner
uh brought some great stuff to that part
because that part could have been you
know the the you know he's in he's a
he's an ax a husband he he uh
you know he's he he doesn't want to take
the kid and look after the kid at the
weekends he's a maybe a bit of a slob
he's a bit of a dreamer he maybe was in
a band and it didn't work out he's a bit
disgruntled and unhappy you could play
that in a kind of uh like I think
there's four or five scenes with that
character in the movie and Jack somehow
has a very clever way of inhabiting
sometimes these characters certainly
with me anyway he played in sing Street
he played the lead character's brother
he makes
a small character grow in a very very
cool way without needing extra dialogue
or without ever asking me to like can I
do more or can I be in more scenes he
breathes life into these small
characters or secondary characters
um so I just can't wait to do something
bigger with him I would very much like
to see that I think I love that he makes
the most out of every minute of screen
time that he gets but I need to see him
like Powerhouse lead front and center
that's a good way to put it that he's
the kind of actor who you look forward
to in the seven scenes that you know I
think of tons of those actors that are
like oh you're gonna make something of
this scene it's not just going to move
the plot along now my brain is flooding
with examples
um I wanted to touch on something I
think you might have said this in a
previous interview or my press notes or
something but I love this idea it's
something that I think about a lot and I
think you were talking about what you
wanted people to take away from the
movie and you said the beginning of
something but not the completion how do
you go about knowing that your movie
gives a full and satisfying experience
but while also leaving the door open for
audiences to consider what happens next
yeah I do know what you mean I do know
what I meant when I said that I think
that it's
um I tried to avoid the idea that like
oh this is the end of the movie and
everything is finished because stories
never finish you just choose a point at
which to jump off
and
uh
I you could choose to end on page 78 or
you could go one more page or you could
go five more pages or you could go into
the next day for this character and I
think for me the the challenge of making
a movie is how you begin it and how you
end us and that's what makes it distinct
from TV which goes on and on and on and
on and draws you in and seems to never
end I mean that's the a film has to you
begin and without a bathroom break or a
week break or a t a t break you're gonna
you begin and then you're gonna end and
the audience are going to believe you or
not and trust you and I find that the
point to which you're gonna bring down
that that blade on the end of the movie
and make that final curse
to me it's better when
you don't make a big statement about
that ending and wrap it all up and have
everything finished but that when you go
this character got some satisfaction
there in that scene but it doesn't mean
that tomorrow is not going to be a
challenge
and I didn't want to do a thing about
you know Flora from the flats who has
all these challenges and suddenly she
finds a guitar in her whole life she's
like Beyonce or she's winning Awards I
wanted to make it
that she had taken this step in her life
towards something new but she's still
gonna have challenges the next morning
still gonna have to pay her rent and
she's still probably gonna scream to her
son and they're probably gonna argue but
they're better and they've made some
steps towards repairing their the damage
that that let's face that she's done in
their relationships what makes it feel
real and mean more and that's what
that's what keeps it on your mind well
after the movie ends too and I
appreciate that very much he's thinking
like work about go or work or that go or
where could this go yeah it's giving
that to the audience so that they don't
feel they've been given a box with
ribbon on them that's all tied up and
done do you have any itch whatsoever to
make a sequel to any of your films I
thought about it but I thought about
sing Street would be a funny sequel
because you could take the characters in
London when they probably went out there
at the end of that film it's like 80
what year is it AG six or seven or
something like that so you could set a
film in London in the late 80s or early
90s
but musically I didn't think things were
as interesting for me then and then I
thought of a sequel to once but then
I don't know I'll probably just disguise
it in another film and call them have
different names or something like that
but no it's nice to end and just be done
with it okay I get it but when I fall in
love with something I get greedy and
want more of it well then the really
great example of that the only one that
works for me is the link laser movies
so I'm so glad that I mean the the other
two two and three don't take from one
but they also don't you know but they do
work as a as a as a continuing Saga or a
story but I don't normally I like a film
to just it ends and that's it you don't
get any more I'm sorry it is over I very
much understand that you bringing up
sing Street gives me an excuse to ask a
question you've probably moved on from
this but I think about it Non-Stop and
I'm still very sensitive about the fact
that that was probably one of the
biggest Oscar snubs of all time I'll
never stop thinking about it I was it a
surprise to you when it didn't get the
original song nomination and why do you
think it was shut out that year because
for the life of me even after all these
years later I can't process it well I
tell you I never got into filmmaking to
even think about it anymore so so and
it's very important for me
to having had the look of once winning
an Oscar that was never the plan and so
it's very important as a filmmaker to
try and
never go for that again because it is
going to limit your work and you're if
you start and it's very tempting to go
God we actually were in that room and
there's an award maybe we could you know
go down that path
so anything that we any love that my
films have gotten is a surprise to me
because I expect them to be as my early
films were broadcast in my mother's
front room just seven of my friends
that's the most I expect from any of my
films so when anything happens but I
think the reason it's not a good thing
when you've made a small musical in
Dublin and then Damon chazelle releases
a musical that does not help a very good
musical I still feel like it deserved it
deserved that at the very least
nomination it is
happening they can maybe give me like a
lifetime and say we missed
when I'm like 90. sign me up to support
them I'll be there I wanted to refer to
one other quote you gave in our press
notes I have to read this because it's
so specific you were talking about how
the idea for Flora and Son originated
and you said no matter how rich I may
ever become in this world I will always
stop at a dumpster to see if there's
anything there for me you found an amp
and that's what got the ball rolling on
this what is the latest thing you have
found in a dumpster and could it wind up
becoming a movie down the line that's
very good question I did I actually
really finally I I um I was trying to
explain that to somebody the other day
and they were saying why why why why why
didn't you make a story about the amp
and I was like well an amp is a thing I
thought yeah you need something else to
to amplify I could so I traded that out
for a guitar because it's a dumb thing
it's like a bicycle you don't need
anything else to make an acoustic guitar
make noise
um but I then I did actually have a very
funny image the other day I was walking
along or I said that's what I said I
said like when you see somebody walk
down the street they're interesting but
if they have a guitar on their back
they're twice as interesting or so true
dude I mean it's something but a musical
instrument tells you oh there's a
dreamer there's somebody who thinks that
she can perform there's somebody who has
a dream of a song that certainly this
instrument gives it's a great prop in a
movie it suggests all these stories to
me but I did really finally walk down
the other day and there was a guy
walking I mean two guitars over his
shoulder
[Laughter]
and I was like is that twice as
interesting because they were literally
you just found two guitars and was
carrying them and I was like you know
and actually what I realized is not as
interesting because he looks like he's
trying to sell them there
oh that's curious
walking down the street carrying them
now my mind is spinning out of control
with the narrative possibilities there
I'm gonna end with one question about
your next film because I know it was
very important uh to you to set flora
and Son in Dublin I believe with your
next film you're going back to New York
what is it that's calling you back to
New York City right now well maybe I am
it depends on whether I can get
financing or not but I'll maybe I'll
find that out now in Toronto we manifest
things here you will get financing yeah
yeah I can go out cap in hand at the end
of the screening
um there's a couple of projects and one
or two of them are set in New York I
mean it's
still even though I guess probably not
the artistic center of the universe at
the moment because everybody's been
priced out and the kids aren't there and
they're not doing their thing same as
Dublin it's just not happening and it's
primarily because there's no young
people are there no people can you know
young people can afford to do anything
there so it's that old story so what the
next city is I have no idea or the next
town or whatever but that is a problem
with New York for sure so you kind of
have to make up your own stories when
when you're there and they also know
like I don't know it's hard to
for me it's like you don't want to be
making something that is claiming to be
the next big thing
because who knows what the next big
thing is musically because it's moving
so fast and fair yeah fair to think
about it that way but every single movie
I know that's coming up and has your
name on it I know it's Gonna Fill A very
particular place in my heart that I
can't get enough of I'm so happy to have
it yet another movie from you to watch
over and over and over huge
congratulations
to everybody out there keep an eye out
for the movie trust me do not miss it
and stay tuned for more interviews from
Tiff 2023